welcome back to me rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and with frickin Morty season for
coming there remain mysteries about the
series that it looks like this new
season might start to answer now it's
fun to wonder what professional title
mr. poopy butthole might have now but
there are even darker truths lingering
from the first three seasons that we
have got to address and here to help me
do that it's my buddy and fellow Rick
and Morty fanatic Danny brickowski hey
man oh well hey the hair I'm glad to be
here with the air kiss Derek and I with
the Danny as Danny
now we realized that there are actually
two of the deepest darkest questions
that drives these series of Rick and
Morty first after years of struggling
with alcoholism depression
self-destructive hedonism in despite
sincere attempts
why hasn't Rick been able to kill
himself and - what is evil Morty's
agenda / origin I mean basically what's
he being all evil about doesn't seem
very Morty to me yeah well after talking
it over Danny and I believe that these
two questions have one unified answer
and if you'd been watching Rick and
Morty through these same warped lens
that we watch it through the clues have
been there the whole time
whoa join us as we break them down in
this episode oh let us start by looking
at Rick's death wish something that has
been painfully evident to us since his
suicide attempt at the end of
auto-erotic astonishing Rick has a
conflicted relationship with his own
mortality he seeks out ways to keep
himself alive forever but at the same
time constantly yearns for that sweet
release of death right we see this
contrast in the season 3 episode big
trouble and little Sanchez where Rick
engages operation Phoenix Rick
successfully transplants his
consciousness into a younger version of
himself tiny Rick but this attempt at
immortality backfire spectacularly when
he communicates his inner fears through
the Performing Arts the song that tiny
Rick improvises and his dance entitled
let me out
showcase his cold feet not only does he
fear the death of his original body but
he also seems to fear the eternal light
that would be granted to him by
operation Phoenix right too scared to
live too scared to die also in season 2
episode 1 a ricky'll in time there's a
version of Rick who almost gives up his
life in order to save Morty
Rick realizes and embraces the idea that
the world would be a better place
without him okay
this be good Morty be better than me I'm
not okay with this I am NOT okay with
this - nice he's offered a way out of
this selfless ending he snatches it
mm-hmm and there are countless moments
throughout the series that show Rick's
disdain for his own life and his desire
to escape it there was his half-hearted
suicide attempts and fruit peel and
there's his alcoholism a slow and
grueling form of suicide yet depending
who you talk to and there's the true
meaning of the term what a lot of dub
dub
that's just Rick's stupid nonsense
catchphrase it's not nonsense at all in
my peoples tongue it means I am in great
pain please help me and the one time
that we see a Rick die apparently
according to Rick's own will it happens
in the episode that introduces evil
Morty close Rick counters of the Rick
kind in this episode the evil Rick
swarmed by a bunch of Morty's shouts
right and this moment sheds light under
what we think is the connection between
evil Morty and Rick's death wish whether
he's doing it consciously or
subconsciously Rick is grooming his
Morty to become evil Morty in a future
timeline so that he can do what Rick is
too afraid to do kill Rick yeah well we
certainly have seen Morty changing over
the course of the series many people
point to his murder of fart in Morty
Knight run has a huge chaining point
where Morty started to embrace his Rick
side Morty has gone from being a
spineless bumbling idiot and a pilot to
a competent and self-aware hero even
calls out the more deenis of other
Morty's like he does in the courtroom
scene of the Rick shank redemption how
is this a fair trial our lawyer is a
Morty one way that we like to mark
Morty's progression is through his
choice of adventures the Morty picks an
adventure episode has become as beloved
a tradition as interdimensional cable
these episodes are perfect snapshots in
the progression of Morty's character yes
Morty's first chosen adventure is a
fairy tale
literally modeled after Jack in the
Beanstalk here Morty is naive and
idealistic as constantly happens in his
adventures with Rick he is horribly
traumatized in Morty second adventure
indicators three return of world ender
Morty is more world-weary and competent
disarming Rick's bomb and leading the
team to victory over
this rink and the season 4 trailer
teases a third morty adventure you know
what this one counts as one of your
adventures if the first adventure is
fairytale themed in the second superhero
theme this one looks like it's going to
be Dungeons & Dragons II and we all know
that's the darkest and most mature of
tabletop RPGs it is and if we want to
follow the idea of Morty going dark the
trailer shows them turn into a literal
monster issue some Tris is a Nazi it
doesn't get much darker than na but
we've already seen more to go pretty
sinister like in this scene from the end
of the world leader Lee conspiracy where
the way Morty talks to summers
ex-boyfriend Ethan is pretty similar to
the way Michael Corleone talks to
Connie's abusive husband in The
Godfather made my sister cry Ethan you
mess with their body image look Morty
Shh
careful Ethan your s'more is burning and
I do a far shoot played with my sister
you think that could fool the car Leon
Morty is breaking bad but for him to
become evil Morty wouldn't he have to be
like a time traveler I'm in close Rick
counters in that episode we see Morty
and evil Morty side by side well there
is another clue in that episode when
Morty meets the cultist of the one true
Morty they say so if Morty's c-137
is the one true Morty and this is his
return then he must have already been
there or a future version of him has a
future version of him that we already
know is charismatic enough to say win an
election exactly maybe even Morty
started the very prophecy that our Morty
fulfilled
mind blown oh yeah Rick knowing that he
wanted to die but also knowing that he
would never have enough will to take his
own life put into play a plan to create
an evil and sadistic Morty that would
eventually take him down a plan that
started in episode 1 where he issued
Morty this secret command help me escape
when does he say that right here he just
burns well remember when I said you had
to watch it through the same warped lens
that we do by that I meant in Reverse
because we're insane we're Loco
it's been there the whole time just
watch it backwards time is relative
[ __ ] suicide by lordy it's canon and
thanks to one of our good friends for
sending that into us otherwise I don't
know if I would have ever spotted it 100
years suicide by Morty guys it's an
agenda in the works since the beginning
because the entire plot of Rick and
Morty has apparently been a conspiracy
what do you think is evil Marty's true
purpose comment down below with your
theories and subscribe the new rock
stars for more breakdowns on analysis of
Rick and Morty especially when season
four comes back in our lives follow me
on Twitter and Instagram at a boss and
follow me on twitter and instagram at
danny forecast hey thanks for helping me
explain this theory Danny want a problem
I don't need to think of Jurong and I
built-in control remotely sorry
[Music]